could you tell us a little bit about the
history and development of 1806 5 this
new course yes ok so this is my
adventure
into the subject of deep learning so
that's a special part of machine
learning a highly important part it's in
the newspaper all the time and students
are graduating knowing about deep
learning and getting good jobs and it's
really amazing so and then the other
beautiful part is that it depends so
heavily on linear algebra you've been
known to say I certainly learned that
projects are far better than exams
students ask their own questions and
write their own programs from now on
projects that's right yeah sort of late
to learn this because with the the 1806
linear algebra totally conventional
course with maybe three exams during the
semester and a final exam and maybe
that's appropriate but it's changing and
then with this new course where the
computers involved and you for example
so I asked everybody to do a project
there is no final exam actually there's
no exam at all I shouldn't like to say
this but it's really what the subject is
is having an idea of how ok I'll use
deep learning for some things what did
that feel like to try something new
pedagogically oh it's fun you know I I
like teaching and this is a subject
where students just come from everywhere
because they know what stuff to learn
and they've heard about it and they some
of them know more than me and then they
those students write even better
projects yeah it's just so so think so I
do the lectures for the first
three quarters of the course and then I
try to get them to present which is a
great experience for them takes a little
purging to get them but yeah yeah it's
really just wonderful what insights have
you gained about having more of a
student-led course in a project-based
course I need anything that you realize
holy but finally that that's how people
learn by doing their that you couldn't
give them a better way to learn than
then create a project it usually it's on
some topic they know about or they
they're interested in like how do you
find a criminal in a you know a bunch of
people what it's yeah it's just it's
it's a very effective way to learn and
something it's something that gets
remembered we're taking doing exam
questions that I might make up sort of
Massey questions I don't know if that's
remembered ten years later but I think
people project are is there anything you
learned from teaching it this way like
something that maybe went wrong in the
logistics of facilitating these projects
that next time you want to do
differently well sure that I didn't have
any idea what to expect
yeah really and maybe the students
didn't either they said what's the
project
well one student had said unwisely when
are their projects do I thought what's
that I mean I hadn't even thought about
project so I thought okay you've asked
for it so so we decided that the last
the end of the semester the final day is
class which is two weeks away projects
are due to come in and then some of
their class is able has a chance to
present
their project in the in the last weeks
but not everybody because it's a big
class so it starts with each student or
each group it could be two or three
students together sends me an email
about their plan mm-hmm and I respond I
usually respond wonderful and maybe I
have an idea of a reference or two that
they could look at but and then they
then they just do it yeah it's really
nice
very nice do give them any feedback
along the way if they ask for it
yeah and if I do you know they usually
they'll know more about their subject
than me but but maybe what they learn
also is presenting that's a important
thing so it's really more it's richer
than taking a exam mm-hmm well the
viewer may think okay professor Strang
says no more exams I don't know if I so
don't quote me on that please in 1806
five in one of the videos you talk about
grading students work and you tell them
that although this is important to grade
their work it's not your main concern
that your main concern is actually
learning with them right this is what I
want to say the most and I say it to
every class I teach it near the start of
the semester my feeling about what my
job is is to teach you things or to join
you join with you in learning things as
has happened today it's not to grade you
so typically the first few days of class
these guys ask you know what's a class
average gonna be how are we gonna be
graded I don't have any answers for that
stuff so I say what is totally true that
I'm not I don't feel my main job is to
grade them that
my job is to teach them or learn with
them and that's what I continue to do
and gradually they begin to believe you
know at the beginning it's they would
still think okay but he's got to give me
a B or C or an a but really that's not
what 1806 5 is about a grade it's just
not what advice do you have for new
professors starting out in teaching oh
well
probably this interview was expressed
most of the thoughts I have about in the
class yeah yeah use big chalk if it's
especially if it's a large class it
helps your writing get your writing
looks impressively level even because of
the chunk and and don't rush and don't
think you have to cover everything just
just stay with the class yeah yeah well
so again it's it's the best job possible